Election officials in Afghanistan are still counting ballots in the Presidential election.
But the final result expected later this month could be delayed.
And Afghan Election Commission says, it still must clear about 650 serious complaints of fraud.
Many of the complaints have been lodged against supporters of incumbent President Hamid Karzai.
His main challenger, former Foreign Minister Abdullah Abdullah told reporters,...
...he's concerned about the election process...
...and wants the international community to investigate.
My concern is that if we cannot save this process,...
...if the future government of Afghanistan is based on fraud,...
...on top of every other problems that we have,...
...there will be illegitimate rule.
Abdullah's comments came as the New York Times quoted unnamed Afghan and Western officials...
...as saying Mr. Karzai's supporters created as many as 800 fake polling stations...
...that produced hundreds of thousands of fraudulent votes.
The Times says, the votes counted for Mr. Karzai at some polling stations...
...may be ten times higher than the number of people who actually voted.
Mr. Karzai's supporters have so far denied taking part in efforts to rig the election.